Y
STILL MAY BE FIGHTING TERRORISTS
IN AFGHANISTAN MANY YEARS FROM
NOW.
HERE WITH US NOW, LARA LOGAN.
I NOTICED A TWEET OF YOU EARLIER
TODAY SAYING CAN WE STOP
PRETENDING THE TALIBAN ISN'T A
TERRORIST ORGANIZATION?
THEY DID RELEASE ALL OF THESE
TERRORISTS THAT WERE IN PRISON
WHEN THEY IMMEDIATELY TOOK
POWER.
SO THAT GAME, THAT -- WE NEED TO
STOP PRETENDING.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> YEAH, SEAN.
ONE OF THE MOST ABSURD THINGS
FOR US TO WITNESS -- I DON'T
KNOW.
I KNOW THERE'S PEOPLE AT HOME
LIKE ME WATCHING IN AND
THINKING, LIKE HOW CAN THEY
STAND AND LIE ON THIS SCALE?
IT'S JUST EXTRAORDINARY.
THEY KNOW WELL THAT THE TALIBAN
AND AL-QUAIDA AND ISIS, THE
DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN THE GROUPS
ARE JUST POWER STRUGGLES,
INTERNAL POWER STRUGGLES.
SOME OF IT IS PART OF DISSECTION
OPERATIONS.
IF YOU'RE DESIGNATED AS A
TERRORIST ORGANIZATION, YOU MOVE
YOUR PEOPLE TO THE TALIBAN.
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT DESIGNATED.
YOU OPERATE LIKE THAT.
WHEN JOHN CAMPBELL'S FORCES
UNCOVERED THE LARGEST AL-QUAIDA
BASE FOUND ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD
IN 2015, WHERE WAS IT?
IN SOUTHERN AFGHANISTAN?
WHO WAS IT?
30 SCARE MILES WHERE THE TALIBAN
AND AL-QUAIDA WERE TRAINING
TOGETHER, WORKING TOGETHER.
THEY'RE MARRIED IN EACH OTHER'S
FAMILIES.
YOU JUST HAD THE ACTING
PRESIDENT OF AFGHANISTAN, THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT, WHO UNDER
THE AFGHAN CONSTITUTION IS NOW
PRESIDENT.
NOW THEIR LEADER.
HE TOLD ME IN AN INTERVIEW THAT
WHEN THEY PICK UP THESE
PRISONERS OR WHEN THEY PICKED
THEM UP FROM THE BATTLEFIELD AND
INTERROGATE THEM, THEY FIND
TODAY THEY'RE ISIS.
TWO WEEKS AGO TALIBAN.
TWO YEARS AGO AL-QUAIDA.
IT'S AN ON GOING CIRCLE.
THERE'S IS NOT A COUNTER
TERRORISM EXPERT THAT WILL TELL
YOU ANYTHING ELSE WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE.
>> Sean: ADAM, YOU'VE HAD THE
CHANCE TO NEGOTIATE WITH THEM.
CLEARLY THEY ARE TERRORISTS.
NOW WE HAVE AMERICANS WITH A
VERY STRONG LIKELIHOOD THAT BY
MONDAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
LEAVING AMERICANS BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
WHICH IS WHY WE BROUGHT THE VICE
PRESIDENT NOW ACTING PRESIDENT
ON TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY CHANCE
THAT WE CAN SOMEHOW FIND THESE
AMERICANS LEFT BEHIND AND GET
THEM TRANSPORTED TO THE NORTH TO
SAFETY AND WE CAN EXTRACT THEM.
ARE THEY A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION?
WHY DID JOE BIDEN NOT ACT AS
THEY WERE TAKING OVER LARGER AND
LARGER PORTIONS OF THE COUNTRY
GOING BACK TO MARCH, APRIL, MAY
AND JUNE AND JULY?
WHY WOULD HE NOT HAVE MOVED UP
ANY EXIT WITHDRAWAL TO A POINT
WHEN IT WAS SAFE AND WE
CONTROLLED KABUL?
>> IT'S HARD FOR ME TO EXPLAIN,
SEAN.
THE END OF THE DAY -- LET ME
COMMENT, THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU HAVE A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION AND NO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
YOU GET BEHAVIOR LIKE THIS.
SO WHEN WE PULL OUT WITH OUR
TAIL BETWEEN OUR LEGS, THERE'S
NOTHING TO STOP THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR AND RELEASING ISIS-K
PRISONERS.
I LISTENED TO THE TV WHEN THE
TALIBAN SPOKESMAN THAT SAID
THERE'S NO PROOF THAT OSAMA BIN
LADEN PERPETRATED 9-11.
THAT KIND OF BRAZEN TALK TELLS
YOU HOW THEY'RE FEELING.
THEY'RE FEELING GOOD.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THE SECOND THING ABOUT THE DATE
MONDAY, YOU DON'T DEFINE A
MISSION BASED ON AN ARBITRARY
DATE.
YOU DEFINE A MISSION BASED ON AN
OUTCOME.
THE ANYTHING HERE IS GET
AMERICANS AND OUR ALLIES OUT
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT'S WHAT THE MISSION SHOULD
BE, NOT MONDAY.
WHO CARES ABOUT MONDAY?
>> Sean: LARA, LAST WORD.
WHAT DO YOU SEE FORESEE AS OF
TUESDAY?
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS TO
RECOGNIZE THE AFGHAN PRESIDENT
AND OUR ALLIES FIGHTING.
THE UNITED STATES NEEDS TO DO
WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE A
LONG TIME AGO AND DECLARED THE
TALIBAN A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION, WHICH THEY ARE.
WE NEED HUMANITARIAN SUPPLIES
INTO THE VALLEY TO HELP THESE
PEOPLE AND CONGRESS NEEDS TO
ACT.
CONGERS AND LEADERS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
THIS IS A REPUBLICAN-DEMOCRAT
PROBLEM.
AMERICAN WEAKNESS IS A PROBLEM
FOR EVERY AMERICAN.
THEY NEED TO ACT TO PASS LAWS TO
MAKE IT ILLEGAL FOR ANYONE TO
GIVE ASSISTANCE TO THE TALIBAN
BECAUSE THEY ARE A TERRORIST
REGIME.
>> Sean: A DISASTER AND IT'S
GOING TO GET WORSE.
I PRAY TO GOD I'M WRONG.
I DON'T THINK I AM AND I DON'T
THINK LARA OR ADAM ARE.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, SEAN.
>> Sean: I WIS